I think role models are absolutely essential
especially in this part of the world, especially
in the Middle East. I think for the most part
there are major success stories to talk about
be it private sectors, the public sectors
even in the-- actually knowing about it. I
think based on some surveys that I read about
two weeks ago when the majority of the outer
world were asked about most of the time - - or
religious figures. Well there are many non
political figures that should be role models.
There are scientists, there are artists, there
are you know people that are architects that
like for example00:56 [inaudible] people should
know about. There are wonderful examples of
role models across the outer world that can
provide a lot of global inspiration for a
large segment of the population in the other
world but people need to hear about them,
people need to know about them and I think
they can inspire the youth to aspire to become
whatever they want to be[inaudible].